this video is sponsored by book Walker
whatever that timer
though they all stop
[Music]
what are you doing step grow since the
beginning of mankind we have always been
drawn to fire it's mesmerizing flames
dancing and weaving was what kept us
alive and warm allowed us to cook food
for more nutritional meals that helped
us to develop our evolving brains which
is why in the modern age almost as if by
instinct we are still drawn to a
dumpster fire no matter how dangerous or
smelly or incestuous it may be domestic
girlfriend or to go buy his Japanese
name domestic na kanojo or Coconino
girlfriends or Boca no girlfriend
Academy a-- is the latest romance to
spice up this anime community a full-on
4k 60 frames-per-second car crash in
slow motion that explodes your beautiful
roaring did not related by blood flame
that we as dumpster moths can't help but
fly into so if you're feeling happy cuz
car gear summer has finally cured your
depression this season have no fear
domestic job friend has come along just
in time to bring it back again see this
show isn't just any romance anime this
is the next level of romance anime you
know how in most anime romances it takes
ten decades of character standing around
wondering if they should confess and
then when we finally get some hot steamy
hand-holding action they get
cock-blocked once again by everyone's
favorite third wheel fireworks can yeah
that's why I'm calling well do you know
how many [ __ ] good matches your room
well luckily domestic girlfriend is so
much more realistic because it starts
with a dude having just smashed a bird
oh and that dude's got a crush on his
teacher old his dad's getting remarried
oh and his new stepsisters are gonna be
his teacher and the girl he lost his
virginity to oh and they're gonna be
living in the same house and starting a
step-sibling love triangles
spicy face pricing now you may be
sitting here thinking wow this sounds
like it can only end badly but I can
assure you despite what sounds like an
absolute disaster of a premise it only
goes downhill from here
see when talking about domestic
girlfriend's we have to describe things
in terms of spice level because
literally every episode something
happens that will give you the
uncontrollable urge to go well that's as
feisty boy step-sibling crushes
teacher-student relationships affairs
with married men love pentagrams love
rivals watts max find out on the next
episode of two girls one brother but
don't worry it's not some creepy siscon
kind of show you know I swear I swear
too good I mean we all know it's not
incest anyway if you shout no cry mode
we take a look at some of the spiciest
peppers in the world we have the famous
ghost pepper at around a million
scovilles the Trinidad scorpion which
beats even that and the granddaddy the
Carolina Reaper and a whopping 2.2
million Scoville units
a pepper so spicy that has even
hospitalized some people for eating it
and yet that is nothing compared to
getting rejected by your first love and
almost double suiciding with her who's
also your teacher stepsister making out
with your other stepsister flirting with
your club president only to then walk in
on your teacher stepsister buttering her
muffin to the thoughts of her ex-lover
while you just stand there and watch
while in motion or j-pop place in the
span of a single episode it was now I
know what you're thinking
oh look giggles talking about another
trashy sister show does he want this to
be the new era manga sensei or something
who-who prefer and I take offense to
that because it should be obvious that
these two shows are nothing in life I
mean I might have called them both trash
but one is a flaming dumpster and the
other is a flaming dumpster that the UN
definitely wanna ban not to mention if
you compare the two protagonists you got
the virgin Masamune fantasizing over a
single weak source of a little sister
who'd probably spontaneously combust
with our constant
and attention so he has to play man
slave and here we got nuts whoa already
got laid [ __ ] dual-wielding in sets at
this point while juggling other girls
reaching levels of Chad never before
thought possible
and this isn't even mentioning the girls
because what I can respect to someone
who knows what they want and they
[ __ ] go for it
cuz if you're an anime girl and someone
tells you that you can't be with the
protagonist because of some bizarre
reason like your family or something you
just need to hit them with one of these
[Music]
yes this time we've got the sister the
sister who's also your teacher the shy
club president and a girl who's glops
enough semen to put her into clinical
depression I'm just kidding Momo is a
[ __ ] angel and deserves with a love
care and attention and semen she wants
now I know I said before that nothing
could compete with Hina as the order
stepsister that's also your teacher but
in my calculations I forgot just how
much Rui can tip the scale because you
see in life there are these mythical
creatures that we cannot confirm the
existence of and Rui is one of those
creatures of legend the sacred being we
know only as
[Music]
remote remote plus she's a shorts blue
haired anime waifu so I'm feeling pretty
hopeful for her chances because of all
the other shorts will you add anime wife
news who got to live happily ever after
with the person they love like so yeah
I'm feeling quite hopeful then the thing
about this show is that no matter how
much destruction and disaster was
happening on-screen
I couldn't peel my eyes away from it and
you gotta admit you're morbidly curious
too aren't you watching domestic
girlfriend is like building a death
coaster in roller coaster tycoon then
letting people on the ride to see what
happens next
you know the roller coaster is gonna fly
off into a crowd of people causing
massive destruction because that's the
way you built it you know it's gonna
happen but you watch anyway because
secrets this didn't have big back button
yeah and see I feel like there's a
secret to the spicy formula that is
domestic girlfriend and that's hentai
all right hear me out it is quite well
documented that hentai is an art form
that rivals the likes of Picasso Andy
Warhol and that toothbrush scene he
needs more the guttural but you must
remember that it runs on its own rules
not bound by the laws of reality we're
fat ugly businessmen are the model of
peak masculinity and hips are sentient
beings that can move on their own
because that world isn't the same 20-19
world we live in now I bet they don't
even ask the like button for consent
before smashing it so when watching an
episode of domestic girlfriends you may
wonder how they can pack so much spice
into every episode but once you realize
it runs on hentai rules it makes perfect
sense
we've got levels of cooking not seen
since netter are a Genesis Guren Gallion
we've got people who are allergic to
closing doors because you can't spell
spicy without spy we've got every
conceivable vanilla hentai setup you can
ask for the older sister is having a
beer how long till she passes out on the
sofa and the guy tries kissing her two
minutes
Jesus it was literally tear it oh we
couldn't make this more hentai if we
tried
what are you doing step that brings up
an important question why would I want
to watch a hem tight without the banging
in it doesn't that defeat the entire
point i can't jack off to this and
that's a very good question and I think
the only proper response is bro if you
set your mind to it you can jack off to
anything see the advantage of going by
hem tie roars is that it allows your
series to become plot heavy because in
this art form it needs to be plot heavy
because you don't want to waste precious
time with people or not banging so you
constantly need spicy things to be
happening and surprisingly that's
entertaining as [ __ ] cuz why would you
want to watch some vanilla sexy in any
way when you could just see characters
get gored and showered with depression
and this leads me to believe that the
unreleased full title of the show is
actually domestic na kanojo ex-con azoic
scanners oh don't look at me like that I
know you got that reference of course
with all the spiciness I witness in the
runtime of the show it made me more bit
ly curious to see how big the car crash
the manga would be and what I found was
my absolute worst fear that I did I
really [ __ ] enjoyed it all right just
let me explain
well the start of the series is a spicy
mess as it moves on adequate time is
given to really flesh out the characters
and make them relatable even some
characters who I wasn't a fan of
initially won me over and before you
know it you're invested despite all the
semen demons vying for a taste of nuts
hoooo see no one ever acts in a way
that's completely inconsiderate or
douchey everyone's just been put in a
[ __ ] up situation and they're trying
their best to handle these messy
feelings that they know they probably
shouldn't have for example for the
full-on schooldays disaster Routh this
could go nuts or never goes out of his
way just to get his dick wet every time
a go opens her gate of Babylon for him
he genuinely cares about everyone around
him and acts in a way that tries to make
everyone happy so it's hard to hate him
because despite how [ __ ] stupid and
naive his actions can be you want
everyone to be happy too but you also
know that because of the way things are
set up
that's impossible someone or everyone is
gonna end up with their heart broken so
it's less of a case of
stupid idiots and more of combine this
with the same spicy plop aggression that
will continue to make you shout well
every few chapters and you have yourself
a really compelling reads things
continually happen even if you know it's
all just melodramatic junk food [ __ ] but
you're invested enough in the characters
to keep you turning the next page unlike
you normal harem romance where you have
200 chapters of well they won't they
know they will no they won't
ok can something just happen can please
something happened please just something
happen then just as you're about to give
up all hope they finally confess and
maybe kiss and then the show just ends
ah more thing in domestic girlfriend is
ever static time actually progresses at
a reasonable pace and you see characters
going through different stages of their
lives without spoiling anything that
happens the plot eventually moves past
everyone being in high school you get to
see how characters tackle relationships
when I have things like job aspirations
college and responsibilities to worry
about characters face repercussions for
the actions they take and they learn and
change from it action never comes
without consequence and oh boy is there
a lot of [ __ ] action so even though
when reading a normal anime romance your
emotional states may go something like
this
domestic girlfriend is more like to me
domestic girlfriend is the perfect
melodrama blending human characters who
develop over the course of the story who
some of the most ridiculous plot
progression that is undeniably melodrama
trash but you want to know what happens
next cuz you're invested in the
characters which leads me to believe
this may actually be a good manga with
trashy moments in it or a trashy manga
with good moments and III haven't quite
figured out which way around it is yet
well I initially read ahead just to see
how trashy became I ended up marathoning
the entire series in two days so even
though I came in was the complete
intention of memeing the [ __ ] out of
everything it's become my newest
obsession that I can't recommend enough
so if you want a really addicting drama
to read go pick this up and if you need
any more reason unlike the anime the
manga has got sparked in
also you didn't hear this from me but
they're these things called 0.5 chapters
which aren't necessarily there to move
the plot along but I think they're worth
reading anyway because you might find
something they'll take the manga to what
we'll call hey guys hope you enjoyed
that video thank you very much to book
walker for sponsoring this video I
didn't have an official sponsorship with
them scheduled this month but I was like
look I'm making a domestic girlfriend
video whether you want to be involved or
not because there's no way I'm not gonna
talk about this series you can get all
of the domestic girlfriend volumes
available on book Walker in the link
below and they are even doing this as
the sign will puff so you can get all of
the new chapters as they come out in
Japan just make sure you search for the
domestic girlfriend serial in the search
bar if you want the sime or pub chapters
and as always new users can use coupon
code Giga for five dollars off just the
fair warning though guys if you do pick
up this manga don't expect to stop until
you've completely caught up and feel the
void of having no new chapters to read
because holy crap is this an addicting
read there I've warned you don't come
crying to me when that feeling of
complete emptiness hits you once you've
caught up you know what I'm saying right
margaritas anyway that's it for me
I've been gigging and I'll see you all
next time